défendre la ville défendre pour tous
d'où le ben de fendre le savoir vivre
dit essayer de développer d aider la
société l'écriture ricardo bofill dans
les haut parleurs musique entraînante
ce soir les visiteurs des arcades du lac
découvre la démarche de son architecte
pendant une vingtaine de minutes
enfants et parents s'émerveillent devant
des projection laser sur les façades du
viaduc ses poulains sont ils étaient
bien si tu es jolie les lumières bon on
s'est bien amusé et c'était bien ouais
bah oui elle faisait très près via les
couleurs c'était extraordinaire
j'étais magnifique pareil
la bande son a été choisi en hommage à
certains chanteur décédé et à
l'architecte
autre objectif insuffler des messages de
fraternité à l'image de ce bâtiment
c'est une architecture qu'il est
remarquable est le remarquable justement
dans le sens où il fait bon y vivre
il fait bon y vivre et c'est un peu ce
que disait ricardo bofill c'est à dire
essayer de créer une architecture qui
soit qui puisse être une architecture
permettant le rassemblement d'hommes et
de femmes et de vivre dans un
environnement serein et paisible
une notion qui a particulièrement touché
ses visiteurs tous ensemble
c'est déjà ce que c'est quand même un
message qui est assez joli par rapport à
tout ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
le monde là ça franchement ça fait du
bien de voir des petites choses comme ça
qui nous qui nous promet un petit peu
justement la tolérance de ce qu'on a
autour et des différents styles tout un
chacun
l'opération est désormais terminé la
ville souhaite poursuivre la mise en
lumière chaque année d'une partie de son
patrimoine